foreign
you're also an epidemiologist I presume
the prospect of a viral pandemic keeps
you up at night as well no opening with
a reminder of how terrible the covid
pandemic was just so we can all be
properly terrified by the possibility of
the even more dangerous fungal pandemic
that's about to be introduced as if I
didn't have enough to be pessimistic
about I could now add fungus zombies to
the list great also the 1968 title card
might be the most unnecessary title card
to ever title card I think the plethora
of cigarettes in 29 different shades of
beige gave us all the context clues we
required also the third discount John
hey holy Four Weddings in a funeral
bacteria no you like saying no would you
prefer he said yes and lied is this show
on Fox News permanently fixed on one
unifying goal to spread the infection to
every last human alive slightly more
Angry Peter Capaldi here must be a fun
guy at parties I mean he doesn't really
leave mushroom for optimism does he if I
was watching this live I'd switch over
to the nearest sports channel
you're using fungi instead of blood and
different music doesn't make this any
less of a discount Game of Thrones intro
having to be reminded that 2003 was 20
years ago if you keep making me feel
like an ancient one this will be the
last of me watching this series and as
if this title card wasn't enough this
shot alone is an absolute orgy of
evidence that not only is this a Young
Person's room but also that this is a
Young Person's room from the mid-oughts
going straight from drinking orange
juice to Coffee despite all the warnings
and clerks too I'm pretty sure even 8am
would be more appetizing you can get
your homework done Pedro Pascal is not
my daddy in this scene concrete guy's
gonna be there yeah they said maybe
maybe I didn't expect the Venn diagram
consisting of characters who have a
passion for concrete and characters who
are complicated father figures would
ever overlap to include Gerard Butler
Tom Hardy and Pedro Pascal but here we
are sniff testing your leftovers I mean
I know we all do it but just like my
grandpa used to say it doesn't have to
be wiffy to make your tummy squiffy what
kind of masochist in 2003 would use this
classic phone case with the belt clip
which made you look super super [__]
cool by the way but still put the phone
in their pocket your t-shirts inside out
oh man that is so annoying but at least
as they can't get any worse going
through your father's drawers trust me
that is asking for trouble and she's
very lucky that the show's commitment to
portraying a wholesome relationship
conflicted with her finding well just go
through your parents drawers and find
out for yourself TV since it's not
actually recommend going three parent
stores and will not be held liable for
any resulting injury nightmares or lost
respect for any family members involved
dad you love biscuits I do
but I'm on
I swear shows mentioning the Atkins diet
is to the mid-oughts with Bayesian
cigarettes are to the 60s Expo bum
positional stickers I think
communicate it with Austin Minnesota and
literally any other time in 2003 why the
[__] does it matter that it's September
why are you telling me this now Macbeth
no I don't hate Shakespeare I just wish
we'd teach kids about the fun ones like
Hamlet homework is due end of class
tomorrow well if the homework's due at
the end of class then that's classwork
there is nothing in that description
that would encourage me to spend any
time with that assignment at home you
should go home panicking in front of a
child and telling them they should go
home but not actually telling them why
they need to go home what the [__]
random lady people out there need to get
right with Jesus three Nails Plus One
cross equals four given yep that's the
way to get the kids into Jesus math I
was thinking we'd make some cookies
chocolate chip
math and raisin cookies I feel the Lord
also I always find it odd when people
spend this kind of religious rhetoric in
the face of violence and death because
the Bible might be the most violent book
that has ever existed all the effort
that went into making me believe it's
2003 just to blow it all by including
2005's murder ball this is some amazing
background suspense that reminds me of
the library scene in it chapter one
regardless of whether you've played the
game or know where this is going or have
no knowledge whatsoever these few
seconds set up the horror of what's to
come perfectly dog knows that she's
about to go down before any of the
humans do and is briefly acknowledged
But ultimately ignored cliche also sure
the dog's acting weird and whatnot but
what we really should be focused on is
how horribly organized this bookcase is
it's [__] chaos comment today from
the Austin Police Department regarding a
rash of violent incidents
the only thing worse than using random
news position to explain what's going on
is having one of our characters not
paying attention to the random news
position where's the cake
for getting cake what makes for getting
the cake even worse though is that
you're gonna be stuck eating raisin
cookies Joel also shows that pile on the
undomesticated dad who's useless at
looking after himself and relies on the
little kid good at life routine this
heavily are screaming from the rooftops
that something is going to happen to
said kid and he asked maybe there were
only four people watching this who
didn't know it was coming but they
deserve to be surprised traumatized too
Mrs Adler because [__] the TV the dog
and the clearly freaked out shopkeeper
that have all told me to stay home
instead I'm gonna wander into my
neighbor's house that has no Britain and
blood all over because I'm only smart
when my dad needs to look dumb look
mananoki could be a fungi infected
zombie but there's also a strong
possibility she's just getting Mrs Adler
back for choosing to make raisin cookies
instead of chocolate chip I mean who the
[__] chooses to make raisin cookies
Grandma Sophia Portobello is nice enough
to stop chasing Sarah just long enough
for Joel to show up Park get out of the
truck grab Sarah and get ready to attack
get in the truck right now also
convenient Joel conveniently has a
weapon in his hand when he exits the
truck despite having no way of knowing
Sarah was in trouble the fungicidal
Animaniac hadn't even left the house yet
no one will be seated as Joel and Tommy
decide aloud which interstates and
highways they will be taking to get out
of town how do you know we're not sick
you're saying it's mostly people in the
city mostly it's Jimmy's Place I might
carry more weight if I had the first
clue who Jimmy was you couldn't have
given us a scene with Jimmy instead of
confirming that kids get bored at school
[Music]
to take a major roadway out of the city
yeah that's so weird Tommy you might
think it's the subtle nods like this
backseat POV scene that have inspired
people to call this the best video game
adaptation of all time but I would like
instead to refer you to the person whose
POV we are seeing this from Nico Parker
along with Pascal and basically every
damn person in the pilot gives such
sincere and engaging performances that
this jumps from being a great pilot
based on a video game to Simply a great
pilot that just happens to be based on a
video game head of the river I'll find a
way a wave that wasn't climbing over the
car but instead had to result in the
being separated all so that he can Tommy
X mock into them a few scenes from now
well one of them at least I realize
these aren't technically zombies but
there are still moments like this that
feel right out of a Walking Dead episode
maybe it's impossible to escape that
comparison but I'm me so you're still
getting a sin yes sir
military sent to protect the people from
viral outbreak actually ends up mostly
being there to kill people whether
they've contracted the virus or not
cliche come on okay okay three sin
removals might seem excessive for one
video but this is likely the only
opportunity I'm gonna get to remove Us
in for one of the best video game
prologues ever committed to disc and
either way Pedro Nails this scene oh so
now you don't give us a specific year
likely because the show doesn't want to
date itself when we get to season four
and wonder why it's still 2023 but in
that case don't [__] date the earlier
scenes we know how time works also damn
these sudden time jumps and their
ability to strip all the momentum out of
a story yeah yeah their hands were tied
by the video game but guess what they're
not do what you want wouldn't have been
interesting to see how Joel deals with
the loss of his daughter in the opening
months and years of the Apocalypse all
you've done now is left the door open
for a disappointing spin-off called oh I
don't know let's say Fear The Last of Us
no one wants eight seasons of that this
is clearly trying to tease us into
thinking that we're seeing a fully
infected individuals stumbling along but
we know that the fully infected move
quickly so why give us a slow zombie
stumble tease unless of course you want
us to keep thinking we're watching The
Walking Dead and we really don't want to
be watching The Walking Dead Schindler's
red Petticoat oh so now you're giving us
the year and what was the point
where they did the thing and why is this
even
it's even time it is what year it is who
cares this is the biggest list of
symptoms I've ever seen these could be a
sign of anything from slight
intoxication to having a nap at a weird
point of the day that now means you're
too awake to go back to bed at a
sensible time so you stay up until 5am
playing video games and just resign
yourself to being a nocturnal Beast it's
me I'm the nocturnal Beast
also this is great information for the
audience and I'm sure it won't backfire
when a snarky YouTube channel takes a
screenshot to make sure it's totally
obeyed by the show in the future
how did you get this and now we have
another scene of a child dying to
demonstrate how Bleak the situation is
and call me a wimp but I think two child
deaths in less than three minutes may be
pushing me to my HBO Max tomorrow we got
street sweeping
or swimmingos
pays more
they'll be the one with the this is
Boston where Yankees fans have always
told me that there is [__] in the
streets so that didn't answer the
question he asked Gore Lieberman shirts
in 2023 and yes I understand the world
has been out of the shirt making
business for 20 years but I'm not buying
anyone was wearing those shirts in 2003
either
[Music]
I don't have a hard time believing that
an overzealous military State could
bring back the death penalty I can also
buy that they do it publicly to inspire
fear and obedience from those pesky
masses but people still have a choice
not to turn up right it just seems so
strange to me that an entire crowd would
turn up for this not just the occasional
sociopath looking for the light in the
darkness is great for the Green Lantern
Corps but in this world I imagine it's
pretty terrible advice I bet more times
than not that light will be attached to
a speeding car a freight train or an
assault rifle
Tess survives this
I'm not
just realized in this universe the fungi
infection spreading was probably why
Firefly was canceled and not because of
the terrible Fox Executives to the sin
and as always is network television
seven
eight
eight you kids
this is the sole objection we hear to
the man skipping a very long line of
people all wishing to send messages to
their loved ones 73k Orlando out Florida
show me where the tower is you can't be
serious Joel it's in Wyoming Wyoming
Joel managed to find his stash in a
matter of seconds instead of having to
inspect every item in the room jump into
some walls pick up some random cup
retrace the steps drop some random cup
restart the day and then finally resort
to checking Google it's just not
realistic reading physical maps I mean
the fungi couldn't wait till after the
iPhone was invented in 2007. what a
fungal ass
pushing your partner over to get in bed
instead of just getting into the bed on
the other side it's Miracle you're alive
there's a very Millennials are alive
Tess would be excellent On The Fringe of
TV sins I mean she would be a regular
mind Hunter oh come on you want me to go
back to the mushroom puns also in a tour
of rocks in isn't it enough things that
may be the biggest sin in television
well except for that 90s show I mean why
the [__] does that exist
[Music]
Robert is terrified of you so you march
out of here all Clint Eastwood is going
to get wind of it and Skip how does she
even know Robert is still alive remember
that this [__] happened it's five for
20 years and you get nowhere you're not
a rebellion
spray paint because having people talk
about the Rebellion actiony stuff is so
much better than actually showing the
Rebellion actiony stuff did 47 years of
Walking Dead on a farm not teach show
writers anything is
I believe it is that is not an answer at
least not an answer that would result in
me agreeing to abandon what little
semblance of home I have at the risk of
being hanged whatever you need whatever
it takes look at her where she needs to
go scenes like this drive me mad Kim's
immediate and unquestioning commitment
here just shows that we could have saved
all of the time if Marlene had just
opened with whatever is on the slip of
paper instead of burying the lead and
expositing us to death I won't tell
anyone about any of this I swear where
are you gonna go this is a valid
question where does Ellie think she
could go we're gonna find out she's
carrying the infection but not showing
any of the symptoms but anywhere she
goes once they check her with the scanny
doodad they'll shoot her on site and not
ask any questions at least should know
this so seriously where is she trying to
go
[Applause]
episode promised a showdown between Joel
and Robert but chooses to kill off
Robert before it could happen
[Music]
a lot of gunfire that neither Joel nor
Tess heard while they were crawling
through the walls so I think you're okay
I can do it you don't have a [__]
you're on your [__] head could you
please
[Laughter]
you get her there safely and they'll
give you what you need fueled up truck
done supplies all of it I know Marlene
is low on options but isn't promising
Joel a truck and a load of weapons and
supplies giving away exactly how
valuable Ellie is to someone who isn't
exactly part of the cause she just said
and I know what you're both capable of
for better or worse so wouldn't it be
better to trust one ear Kim to get the
job done rather than Joel who might be
motivated to hold her for an even higher
Ransom also despite that it sure is
lucky that Marlene is spontaneously
gifted with Joel man who just happens to
have a lost daughter the same age as
Ellie and will use that trauma to
protect her with an instinctual Fury you
all that matters my team will not
jeopardize her well that suggests that
her team knows exactly why Ellie is so
important so how many [__] people
know about this super secret secret at
least importance is becoming less of a
secret and more of a this is definitely
going to end up getting Ellie kidnapped
and Marlene will wonder where it all
went wrong situation also if Marlene was
taking Ellie yourself why would she even
need to risk telling the team why she's
so important shouldn't they just follow
her orders
says the person that just picked us up
so what's the deal with you anyways some
kind of bigwig's daughter or something
something like that okay I know I send
Marlene for letting on how special Ellie
is but at the same time now that she's
trusted her with Joel and Tess why
didn't she just tell them exactly why
she's so special like what if they spot
or bite and have a huge freak out and
decide to kill her I kept saying like
wake me up before you go go
gotcha using Wham as your choice of an
80s reference 80s means trouble code
broken
listen no Joel you listen if you didn't
want your code broken maybe don't leave
two-thirds of the cipher inside the damn
cipher book holy [__] I'm actually
outside neither Joel nor task thought it
would be smart to prompt the child who's
never been outside to not do [__] like
this once outside
for the record we don't ever need to see
someone urinating like ever really man
yep you're doing this by the book and
here's a great example of when it would
be extremely beneficial for Joel and
Tess to have some knowledge of Ellie's
condition [__] Marlene and Ellie
pilot does not contain nearly enough
rearranging of pallets in case you
confused it with Jakarta Indiana
good thing this random Hostess knows who
Dr radna is what would the officers have
done if she didn't I mean don't get me
wrong I'm glad this actor got paid to do
some pointing but that doesn't make the
sequence of events any less confusing
just finishing she still had bread left
you didn't let her eat the bread you are
monsters and nothing can convince me
otherwise
then could you at least give her a hint
as to why you've abducted her okay I'm
guessing the military doesn't want to
cause a panic but this guy seems more
interested in creating attention for us
than making sure this poor woman doesn't
feel like she's about to be executed for
an overdue parking violation walking
walking
excitement this is a cool visual for the
audience but why is the professor of
mycology doing this sure she would be
there to review the results but
shouldn't a pathologist or an
upholsterer be the one to check the
corpse stuffing choosing to own a couch
of this color
in the [__] head admittedly I don't
know anything about the Indonesian
police force but I would hope that in
almost every situation a bullet lobotomy
is in option number one
yeah but until today you also thought
there was no way the cordyceps could
live inside a human body so isn't there
at least a chance that this new strain
could have some vulnerabilities
foreign
look I know this is deliberately extreme
but the fear of fungus among us but who
goes from four deaths and maybe 14 cases
unaccounted for to bombing an entire
city those 14 missing people may not
even be infected there's playing it safe
and then there's blowing up the planet
to make sure it doesn't get hit by an
asteroid do I look like I'm infected
cordyceps by its cover it's what's
inside the counts Ellie she found me
after I Was Bitten I shouldn't shoot you
clearly not Ellie would infect all of us
with laughter at TV sins
tear out a few pages Tess is suggesting
that this 20 year old magazine might
make for good wiping material and I
would argue that anything from the Moss
beneath her feet to not wiping at all
would be more hygienic
tonight it doesn't matter but I mean it
kinda does right man Joel's pessimism is
really starting to take a toll on Tess
and I really think she was on The Fringe
of figuring something very important out
here is it chicken whatever it is I have
very serious Stouts there's a
refrigerated section in Ellie's backpack
so it's most likely a future case of
food poisoning whatever happened to me
to find in the vaccine that's what this
is we've heard this a million times okay
Joel professor of mycology Texas Miller
but have you ever heard this from
someone who is living proof of immunity
or at the very least someone who
survived after being bitten for longer
than you thought possible also why are
Joel and tests so surprised that's what
this is she's a 14 year old kid who
appears to be immune to bites from the
infected how could they not know she was
going to be used to help find a cure I
guess the test just said her and Joel
aren't good people but they're fairly
smart people right also also why the
[__] does Joel care anyway as Tess is
about to rightly say you're not getting
the gear you need in exchange for a
vaccine you're getting the gear for
delivering Ellie so what difference does
it make if they can turn her into an
anti-fungal cream or not this isn't
going to end oil test test death
shadowing can I have a gun absolutely
not okay Jesus fine sandwich and give
them food poisoning too they've already
got a fungal infection Ellie no reason
to make their situation worse you should
get moving yeah you can start by running
up that road running up that hill be
running up that building apparently the
pitch for Last of Us was just like The
Walking Dead But much less of the
exciting dead stuff and much more of the
walking long way or short way I mean
it's the long way or the whiff in dead
way which makes me wonder why Joel
suggested the or [__] dead way how
did you get fit you know the old modern
accusing didn't think there was going to
be anything in there and then one just
came at me out of nowhere I feel like
there's a lot more to Ellie's origin
story than we're being told and I hate
being teased like this the main story
confidently progresses on proud of the
seed it's planted well I just feel left
behind I mean you just balls on you
sister using the male reproductive parts
as the symbol of Courage without
considering everything the female
reproductive parts have to go through or
have go through them or ones who spit
opening
open and dark like bats wouldn't this be
a great time to explain how that
particular fun guy likes to behave at
parties they clearly know it's a thing
and considering it hunts based on sound
waiting until it turns up is a pretty
idea if you need to explain that it
hunts based on sound show teases us with
a piano playing frog only to never show
it again
so gross everyone's respective orifices
survive this funky pond water
Part of Me loves Ellie's childish
playfulness but another part of me
thinks she should be smarter than to
make unnecessary noises in a place that
she can in no way guarantee doesn't have
mushroom monsters present so yes ma'am
ding ding indeed yes ma'am would you
like me to check your luggage yes ma'am
right away man I'm a weird kid no this
is exactly how kids work and Joel having
had one should really know this
one thing I can tell you for certain I
really hope this is the last of the jump
scares because if it's not it definitely
won't be the last of the jump scare sins
kicking a person while they're dead
let's try climbing some [__] floors
with our knees see how you feel then may
I be so bold as to suggest using your
feet for the next flight maybe I could
climb up there work my way around
and open it from the inside or you could
break the doors down I mean in video
games would endorse stop you because
Beyond them lies the nothingness void of
a matrix yet to be programmed but in the
real world that's almost never the case
it's a bit of a mess so I'm gonna need a
few minutes feel free to take this time
to bond or create further tension
between yourself and your co-lead
whatever feels natural where'd you learn
to do that the circus is the knife
flipping really that impressive or is
Joel just making small talk because Joel
should be harder to impress and or
should hate small talk
run Texas Texas what about tests Detroit
it's in Michigan I go to school I know
where Detroit is the depressing fact
that making this statement in our
version of 2023 doesn't necessarily
guarantee knowing things good to see
that the U.S school system may have
actually improved thanks to the
apocalypse how long do infected live
there's others been walking around for
20 years how does Joel know this for
certain in the chaos of the Apocalypse I
can't imagine there's been a lot of
opportunity to track or carbon date the
infected or has he seen a few walking
around wearing it I went to 2003 and all
I got was this lousy fungal infection
t-shirt what
fortunately test arrives just in time to
prevent us from learning anything truly
meaningful about Joel's character now
that might seem harsh but some insight
into whether or not he feels remorse for
beating that guard to death would have
been pretty powerful and since a little
birdie told me we never come back to the
subject it either feels like a wasted
opportunity or one the writers didn't
want to flesh out what now
okay she didn't say the words but that
expression had you better come take a
look at this cliche written all over it
I see you Tess I see you their
connection more than you know this shot
and the following explanation of how the
cordyceps work is so [__] cool a
quick accept your sin removal before I
change my mind in Addison for any
nightmares this will inspire yeah
cooked finally some [__] luck
premature cordycephalibration
or maybe he found a way to travel
through time which involved covering
himself in Jam running through a museum
and peeling his own skin you see he's
not really dead his Consciousness is
just returned to 2003 to prevent all of
this from happening or you could not
assume the best and get the [__] out of
their tests
[Music]
wouldn't this have been a good plan a
Joel also is silent to even an option
Sound Works through vibration and that's
going to be caused by every clunky boot
every squeaky floorboard and every
single breath if silence is what's
required to survive here then I'd
suggest you find another route or Sandra
Bullock
kids
I really feel like this is information
that could have been brought to Ellie's
attention yes
yes
my pants
hello Ramsay man
out of here why hasn't this already
happened there's no way of knowing if
they got them all so why are they
hanging around and talking as if there
couldn't be 10 more ready to pop out and
deprive us of what little anators we
have remaining there yeah I know it
looks scary
all about wood this wood looks pretty
it's pretty interesting then an
infection and then no I don't know fall
a thousand feet to your death is it
everything you hope for asking this
after only two episodes I'm gonna have
to at least see some giraffes before I
make that kind of judgment and it's not
like episode three is gonna be one of
the greatest episodes of Television ever
created with some of the most incredibly
nuanced performances but to film now
will it
it went inside
what is Tess so pissed about that the
truck people went inside or is it where
they parked the truck it's probably the
ladder this gets it I mean one of them's
got to have a map on them right even if
they do it doesn't mean it'll be helpful
unless Tess thinks there'll be a giant
red x that marks the spot of where Ellie
was supposed to be headed have you even
ever mapped before Tess because I don't
think you have
he's infected I'm sorry Tess but dick
move that bite is about as close to the
brain as it gets which means she only
has a couple of hours before becoming
servopolis Al fungi so she really should
have told Joel and Ellie straight away
regardless she definitely should have
mentioned it before entering a building
that she hoped was filled with fireflies
also while killing off test sends the
message that no character on the series
is safe I'm still pretty pissed off that
I only got two animator filled episodes
throwing hand grenades into the marinade
of fuel at the feet of Humanity's Only
Hope for survival
yes you are and you should be and if you
want me to like your character more
Ellie then stop being such a [__] kid
kid
[Music]
and of course the lighter doesn't work
and by that I mean it won't work for all
of the predictable amounts of tension
building sometime until it suddenly does
work
fungalingus I'm sure this shot much like
the last shot of the first episode means
something if you played the game but I
haven't played the game and therefore
this is just 30 seconds of unneeded
post-apocalyptic building porn and I
hate porn
wait trying to play Django with rocks
sounds fun but then 47 [__] rocks
fall over onto your little toe and then
that little piggy can no longer go to
the market because you're sidestepping
your way down the street and everyone
thinks you're doing a terrible at grimly
impersonation it's in miles west of
Boston 10 miles west of Boston don't
underestimate the power of shrooms
people took them 20 years but they
managed to move Canada all the way to 10
miles west of Boston much longer five
hour hike we can manage that saying this
with knees under the age of 30 to
someone with knees over the age of 30.
we're only three episodes in and I feel
like we've already used our walking
walking walking excitements in as far as
it can go in fact I'm less irritated
about them walking all the time in this
series and more irritated that you've
now made me sick of looking at reading
and writing a long-standing sin you're
causing me to send my own [__] sins
The Last of Us and I do not like it but
also walking walking
excitement happy now I said good day
what are you looking out for living in a
world that's 20 years deep into the
apocalypse and asking dumbass questions
like this when mushrooms have taken over
people's brains and are using humans to
eat other humans you are always on the
lookout I think there's a scar on your
head someone shot at me and missed see
that's cool tell me you've never been
shot at without telling me you've never
been shot at no way I had a friend who
knew everything about this game I'm
really glad Ellie has these fun memories
to hold on to and didn't end up losing
that friend extremely tragically I'm
sure if that had happened this arcade
machine would be far more triggering for
her is there anything bad in here just
you ah getting funnier he is not sure
let's open the nope door and have a peek
inside it all the nopeness how has Ellie
survived to 14 does she actually have
the ability to respawn
convenient feminine product is
convenient although your body needing to
eject parts of itself each month is
extremely inconvenient so maybe this
balance is out let's just send periods
I'm not sure if this is a sin for
curious kids being stupidly curious or
if we should say Nellie's obvious
Beginnings to her future as a serial
killer let's just ding it twice to be
safe Ellie
show goes for the oh she really is in
trouble tension paws as if there's a
chance that creative license could
extend to killing off Ellie in episode
three how did it even start if you have
to get bit to be infected then who bit
the first person I thought you went to
school yeah but they only taught her the
stuff that doesn't need to be exposited
to the audience at some point is it a
monkey I bet it was a monkey why do you
have to immediately jump to monkey zelly
not every disease has been caused by a
monkey but also [__] monkeys they're
mean and they throw their [__] at you
cordyceps mutated
it's only got into the food supply you
eat enough of it it'll get you infected
so the tainted food all hits the store
shelves around the same time Thursday
but like everywhere
in it all at once last episode we
discovered that the woman from the
factory in Jakarta went fungicidal
Maniac on Tuesday 23rd September and
that was the first recorded infected so
what we're saying is that by two days
later the flower from that factory was
somehow distributed to all the different
brands was turned into bread and pancake
mix and whatever was sent overseas to
America and Beyond and arrived at
hundreds if not thousands of stores
simultaneously oh and regardless of
delivery days all the products across
the country made it onto the shelf so
that by Friday enough people were
infected to hit a point of no return
this is unbelievably quick unbelievable
the moral don't put dates in your TV
show there's stuff up there you
shouldn't see
now I have to see kids
no I know we're assuming physical harm
here but the mental trauma of witnessing
a mass grave really should be implied
here too
honesty is one of Joel's Greatest
qualities and why we all love him Ellie
should be grateful that he would never
hide a life-changing secret from her
even if the whole world's survival
depended on it right we don't have a
date for when fedro was established but
this is four days after the outbreak and
they have signage created qz set up and
are executing people at will given the
organizational problems we experience
with our actual pandemic I'm calling
shenanigans on anything with fed in the
title pulling this off also prequels
positioning a camera in a way that
results in your god-given right to
defend your property being obstructed by
your god-given right to display your
patriotism you know what looking around
at all the guns and ammo in this room
really didn't give me enough context for
the number of guns and ammo this
character has so thank goodness for this
guns and ammo magazine so I can really
understand how much he likes guns and
ammo guns and ammo 10 Last of Us Lane
the most unbelievable aspect of this
entire episode is that all the wine is
still there and hasn't been stolen by
the military if you had a way to cut the
lock then why did he risk damage to his
vehicle with the other fence so scene
does not contain my mouth eating this
steak you might assume the sin here
would be for over four minutes of
showing us Bill's survivalisting his way
through the apocalypse but you'd be
wrong the actual sin is assuming that we
didn't want to see the full four years
I'm really confused as to how Frank
managed to fall into this hole it's not
even covered and seems to be the only
one in sight to be honest I can barely
see how it would trap an infected why
did Bill miss the perfect opportunity to
build a moat believing that asking this
question will prevent me from sinning
the absence of an explanation if I feed
you then every bone you talk to about it
is going to show up here looking for a
free lunch
and this is not an Arby's well Harvest
didn't have free lunch was a restaurant
Frank would be Employee of the Month the
TV sins bill goes from get the [__] off
my lawn to here take a shower while I
prepare this Michelin star gourmet meal
with red wine pairing I know the power
of boners is strong but why didn't bill
just send him off with a sandwich and a
canteen there is more if I can't I want
to believe me but
I don't know on BS on the man that
hasn't eaten for two days being full up
on this kind of a serving the position
of the food on Frank's plate moves
between shots and yes that is how picky
I have to be to sit in this master class
of Storytelling so I guess I'll be going
then I know he ends up not kicking Frank
out but if Bill at any point thought
Frank would have to leave and walk all
the way to Boston why would he serve him
all this wine friends don't let friends
hike in infected walking areas while
drunk kids it's an important lesson to
learn before the next apocalypse you
know how much these are worth currently
nothing and now it's Bill's turn to be
excellent at TV sins we usually just do
one of these per video but some bastard
is limiting how many sin removals I'm
going to be allowed to give and this
basically counts as one rummaging
through another man's piano bench
without his explicit consent love will
abide I'm very glad we get to see the
bill Frank relationship play out it's
truly beautiful but Frank picking the
one song out of all those music books
that would hit Bill's heart the most is
still some convenient [__]
who's the girl girl you're singing about
there is no girl
I know if you'd have told me that Nick
Offerman butchering a song by Linda
Ronstadt followed by this exchange would
be the most emotional scene of 21st
Century television to date and that it
would be in a damn video game adaptation
I would I would well I wouldn't believe
you okay at least I can't get any more
emotional from here but also emotions
and emotions will always get a skip wait
where's my skip ding what's that City
you love this episode so much that
you're refusing to skip anything and I'm
just gonna have to grow the [__] up and
deal with my emotions
all right then I guess for now I'll just
send that I'm not either of the Beards
in this scene what's your name Bill
doggy dog
skipping three years and assuming once
again that I don't want an entire
multi-season TV show following Bill and
Frank Playing House in the apocalypse
the boutique
are we hosting formal Garden parties now
I don't know why Frank has to be so
dismissive about formal Garden parties
they're so fun especially if they have
the little sandwiches I love little
sandwiches because they're little and
you can eat 30 of them and it's like
you're only eating 27 sandwiches it's
Heaven oh and I have this idea that we
should uh we should use codes for the
radio out of all the Mysteries that have
been presented to us over the last
couple of episodes the how did they come
up with the secret music codes wouldn't
have even made my secondary list of
things I needed to know but here we are
pick it up
like
I can't just one more loop around nope
not buying it I refuse to believe any
relationship survives coerced jogging no
from the strawberries still not having
sex on top of strawberries till you've
tried it guys it's magical unless of
course you're allergic to strawberries
or paid to get sticky or you know what
just don't have sex on top of
strawberries
hold your hand there yes put your
unsanitized hand over an open wound does
anyone in these situations ever think
about the dangers of infections leave
the gas on here the fence the fence will
kill the rest of them if that's true why
the [__] were you insisting on staying
outside with a belly full of lead
poisoning or better still why did you go
out there in the first place
married then you will crush all of these
up put them in my wine
then you take me by my hand
bring me to our bed
and I will fall asleep in your arms
freshly picked strawberries this is
supposed to be about zombies and how
dare you make me feel my own feelings
damn you Offerman damn you mazzin damn
you truck man do you love me yes do you
love me the way I want you to
okay okay well I think I can do this uh
the picture on the wall is wonky oh it
looks like it was drawn by a child the
plant pot is a trip hazard
oh look it's the meat cute death trap
also it's been like 16 years since they
met in this hole and that's what the
grass looks like as Bill or Frank been
mowing it why don't the traps work
better if the grass is overgrown here's
a sin for all of Television the fact
that we are yet to have a
post-apocalyptic Anthology series that
actually focuses on human stories and
the Beautiful Moments that can be found
in the horror not fair on the episode
perhaps but that's what you get for
having the nerve to show us what's
possible I should be furious but from an
objective point of view it's incredibly
romantic sorry to curse the moment but
that's still pretty subjective to
whomever they're probably Joe why would
they leave Tess's name off the envelope
it's as if they already know she's dead
which they should not that's why men
like you and me are here we have a job
to do I leave you all of my weapons and
equipment use them to keep he's dead how
is he still making me feel things Sandy
I'm begging you let me skip
Joel checks the fridge and finds the
battery Parts but why wouldn't Bill have
mention this needed instruction in his
letter that seems like a very important
item that was left out why is the music
on
reset the countdown every few weeks this
playlist would run over the radio
stealing from Lost in a universe where
lost never had a chance to exist I'm
taking a shower
getting this cozy in a house that has
two rotting corpses in the master
bedroom if you told me that the scene at
the piano would be topped in less than
30 minutes by several even more powerful
scenes well you wouldn't even be able to
hear what my thoughts were because I'd
still be a blubbering mess but it's
insane how perfect this episode is and
since and removals are the only way I
show affection here's another three is
an apology for not skipping directly to
episode four okay five but the next
episode had better really suck not sure
if this song actually reminds me of the
opening titles for Sherlock or if I'm
just having a fungus fueled
hallucination either way I'm now more
interested in working on my Sherlock of
us fan fiction than I am in watching
this episode
I can't figure out who Ellie is talking
to here is she talking to me no
seriously is is she talking to me am I a
clown do I amuse her sorry probably got
those references all screwed up I've
never actually watched Joker this breaks
down over time this stuff's almost water
that stuff should be 100 unusable diesel
has it best a 12-month shelf life gas in
general can break down after three to
six months Joel telling me that this old
gas coming from a car currently growing
a substantial amount of moss will work
doesn't make me believe it will work
back in the day we dropped 10 12 hours
on one tank I'm not saying there isn't a
car that can make it 10 hours plus on
one tank but they sure weren't as
plentiful as Joel's making it seem with
this story it doesn't matter how much
you push the envelope it'll still be
stationary
[Laughter]
I'm going to go ahead and give us into
myself because I'm most likely the only
person who actually finds that joke
amusing here
just make you all nostalgic Joel is so
distracted by Hank Williams that he
takes his eyes off the road for an
anxiety-inducing seven seconds this
noticeably hairless bear is the only
issue I have with this faithful
Recreation of the magazine from the game
my page is stuck together uh
[Music]
Olivia Joel is more scared of this
question than he is of the infected
which is fair but it's also an outdated
stereotype about fathers being scared of
the talk
littering seeing this Arby sign makes me
realize those old where did everybody go
commercials in this universe were
accurate predictions of the near future
and for some reason that makes me sad it
also makes me want a roast beef sandwich
and some Horsey Sauce to dip my curly
fries in but also the sad thing earlier
Ellie said I want to see a tank but when
they drive past them Joel doesn't say
that's a tank what a dick all right
that's enough for today and here's this
conveniently laid out turn off because
I'm tired and I'm ready to set up camp
and cook some ravioli hiding far away
from the road is a good idea however
this long and very direct set of tire
tracks is definitely giving away your
position what am I even eating that is
20 year old Chef Boyardee ravioli the
prevailing wisdom regarding the flavor
and safety of 20 year old canned food
appears to be you probably don't want to
[__] around and find out unless it's
absolutely necessary and if your mouth
goes numb it's probably botulism I guess
what I'm saying is that Ellie shouldn't
be assuming gender fungus isn't that
smart
this is too remote for infected anyway
Joe tries to let us down easy with his
hint that no fungus zombies will be
joining us in the episode Joel was
worried about the smoke from building a
fire but not about the light from this
lamp smells kind of good
well that would be Frank's then speaking
ill of the rotting bill
oh what the [__] is that
you don't like coffee jump scaring
Ellie's morning with coffee along with
her inability to not let anything around
her go without giving in to snooping so
the sin is always is Ellie and coffee
long story is it longer than 25 hours
it's not but it's probably gonna feel
like it so I'm coming in hot and heavy
with a request for us skip if the answer
is hope for the world why bother going
on I mean you gotta try it right you
haven't seen the world so you don't know
keep going for family this is why this
story works it's about so much more than
dealing with external apocalypse
problems we get to see the characters
navigate their internal struggles as
well reminding us that these aren't just
video game avatars but real people with
emotions and fears that they must fight
along with the fungus Among Us what if
you don't find him oh well how do you
know I'm persistent oh the superpower of
persistence that always works out in the
end it doesn't get in the way of those
other superpowers like extra human
strength laser eyes and invisibility
nope persistence trumps all this will
work out well for Joel got it pretty
early if you want to grab more sleep I'm
not even tired
kids screw it we've never seen jolby the
type of person to just say screw it so
this is how we know that the writers
were at a loss for how to make something
bad happen we can jog right around this
tunnel not pictured in the scene jogging
having sat through an underworld
Matchstick Min double feature I can tell
you with the utmost certainty that this
is a sin not the Matchstick Men portion
but the underworld portion takes all or
any of the good tastes left over from
Matchstick Men hey please help we're
left to assume this is a trap but are
these guys just always ready to pull
this clearly not that many people are
driving anymore so how often exactly
would the time it would take to set all
this up even be worth it these tires
look much more inflated right before the
crash than they did a second ago because
production put the safety of their
stunned Personnel ahead of continuity I
mean don't get me wrong that is the
correct choice but I still have to send
it
the bad guys who deal out promises say
podcast produced in association with the
same guys who send you emails about your
Amazon account being tampered with
[Music]
they're not gonna hit you all those
Mandalorian episodes have allowed him to
know when he's dealing with people
who've attended the Stormtrooper School
of aiming at things
[__] getting pissed off that the
guy you're shooting at shoots back at
you Joel is amazingly lucky that this
guy chose to run at him when he opened
the door instead of immediately shooting
this scene has devolved into a
convenient medley of things working or
not working also our hero can survive
this seeing the reality on Ellie's face
differ from her attitude in the mirror
earlier is an incredibly powerful
character moment in a world where
children are allowed so little innocence
what little exists for Ellie keeps
getting taken from her all I can do is
remove a sin and appreciation of the
character and the performance not a
single person checks if there are any
Doritos left in this vending machine
Ellie I gotta get in there I can't fit
through Joel absolutely could fit
through the hole in the wall waiting for
three episodes and almost to the 25
minute Mark of your fourth episode to
show us Melanie lynskey you had Melanie
lynskey this whole time and you kept her
from us
for God's sake I delivered you I held
you in my hands I honestly have no clue
what Kathleen is trying to find out or
why status borons from David
cronenberg's remake of The Fly is in the
situation he's in but I'm pretty sure
just being the doctor who delivered said
adult when they were born does not give
you the right to do whatever it is you
probably did I mostly just wanted to
mention the fly but I feel strongly
about the other stuff too also it's so
good to see John Getz isn't it insanely
underrated character actor and I'm glad
he'll be hanging around for a long damn
it this is Henry's work
understand and surprisingly difficult to
take any threat from a person named
Henry seriously I'm genuinely shocked
she's been able to get this many people
to Rally behind her cause also show
continues to not tell us what happened
after the plane crash where the soccer
team was stranded in the woods the guy
with the beard is the first in command
because he has a beard cliche so let's
be honest we all suspected the Kansas
City would be the first to go all Mad
Max nothing in this scene is the least
bit shocking you shouldn't matter to him
you know well you're glad I did right
you're just a kid what a weird way to
say thank you for saving my life Ellie
you put it in your pack
shoot your damn ass off fair enough but
isn't there an in-between place for her
to store the gun having her have to get
into her pack in a last minute kind of
situation doesn't seem smart this smile
after being handed a gun I know it's a
different world than our own but that
doesn't make the smile any less creepy
you yeah Barry is shockingly good at his
job and seems to know what needs to be
done but he follows all of Kathleen's
orders without question that's a very
interesting Dynamic and it's sinful that
they don't have their own show so this
could be explored further these bikes
were left to die here like this showing
us this thing which is obviously related
to the fungus only to then not talk
about it for the rest of the episode how
is this less important than some dude
named Henry get off the building for now
saying this instead of abandoning the
city and I hate to say it moving to Ohio
take a look around first I feel like
that would have been a good idea before
immediately jumping into the room
walking upstairs walking upstairs
walking upstairs excitement
what what do you you doing Joel lightly
Seasons the floor with glass shards
because I don't want someone's sneaking
up on us while we're sleeping but he
doesn't consider barricading the door
even a little bit or not sleeping in
view of the front door where someone
could just shoot him an Ellie before
they even stepped on the glass did you
know diarrhea is hereditary what
yeah it runs in your jeans even cleverly
written poop jokes are still poop jokes
and always a sin Joe they really could
have ended on this beautiful scene with
Joel and Ellie laughing together as the
relationship has grown to the point
where there's space for humor and joy
amidst all the chaos danger and pain and
open the next episode with them being
held at gunpoint that would have been
just as impactful if the story's good
you don't need Cliffhangers watching
Pharaoh Bender steal power on Osiris 4
and thinking yeah we should rule exactly
like him when we take over
[Music]
yeah claiming people will receive a fair
trial while dragging a body with at
least 17 knives stuck in it really
screams due process did it make you feel
I'm sure nobody was happy about making
such a terrible decision but put
desperate people in a situation where
they have to do awful things to get the
bare necessities of life and don't be
surprised when they do those things they
didn't sell out their friends for a flat
screen TV food and Medicine are vital
find a sellout Jeremy to get a burger
and fries from Five Guys you [__] your
ass I'd give him to fedra people gotta
eat completely unrelated let's take this
time to announce our newest TV sin
sponsor your informers inform well I do
hate to side with the midwestern despite
here I've gotta admit their hesitation
doesn't make sense there are some humans
that could stand on principle even at
the cost of their life but in a room
this size there would be at least one
person with a hand immediately in the
air begging to give up any and all info
damn Melanie lynskey's come a long way
from sneaking into Charlie Sheen's
bedroom though I guess after 12 seasons
of Two and a Half Men I might be driven
to Insanity enough to attempt to build
an authoritarian regime as well when
you're done burn the bodies it's faster
faster than what I guess fire is a bit
faster than the corpse barrels I'm
breaking bad but in a world where
mushrooms possess people burning bodies
isn't the faster option it's the only
option
for the three of us
we stick to the minimum I think we can
make it 11 Days please I put away six
pounds of jerky in 11 minutes I guess we
all know who isn't going to survive the
apocalypse
these two are great they'll make an
excellent permanent addition to the cast
but grabbing a pack of crayons and a gun
with no ammo and it doesn't say a lot
for Henry's ability to prioritize
i-beams who dreams of having super
powers and starts with [__] eye Beams
I don't want to poke holes in Henry's
plan but personally if I had 11 days
worth of food I'd have spent it getting
11 days away from this painting in an
unventilated attic
kids I understand this is a sweet
gesture and a confidence booster but how
confident is Henry that that pain is
safe for using on skin this seems like a
rash decision it didn't hurt you so you
hurt us right that's right so we're
[__] tall man that's just the way he
sounds he has an [__] voice Joe tell
him he's okay everything is great
dude I love everything about this Joel
and Ellie are great together but adding
Henry and Sam to this Dynamic chef's
kiss I'm just glad this isn't some cruel
game by the show to completely destroy
us by the end of the episode right we
didn't hurt you so you hurt us right
pointing a gun at someone and not
admitting it might cause emotional or
psychological harm it's home man tone
policing the man you're holding at
gunpoint
as much as I love this scene and Ellie I
think she's maybe being a bit too chill
here while being held at gunpoint who's
her dad season 4 Walter White would you
get these from Bill he's dead I thought
Joel was the awkward one hey Ellie nice
sweater where'd you get it from my Nana
she has dementia
I've heard that in a long time look at
this so wholesome it even warms the cold
dead cockles of my heart I'll puke
afterward of course but at least I've
got the whole warmed up cockles thing
going on now I'm sitting how hard Henry
is pushing on that pencil writing
utensils are a bit of a commodity in the
apocalypse he's up on that graphite
while these highways surrounding
Downtown Kansas City are technically
accurate Interstate 35 also makes up the
western boundary which you've left blank
if you're gonna draw and label a map
fill the whole thing out don't half-ass
two things whole ass one thing Henry
Kansas City is a Subway not just a
Subway several Subways more than 20 and
there's also a Quiznos Blimpie and a
Firehouse Subs you really should do more
research you noticed anything strange
about the city no infected the city
series just wait that joke will kill in
about four episodes in fact you drove
them underground 15 years ago how the
[__] did they manage that and why can't
the other Federal districts replicate it
indoor
survive roll commercials I know he's
only eight but that was some pathetic
goalkeeping we're not doing so good we
maybe the search would go better if you
were helping instead of sitting up in
your childhood room doing nothing he
would be horrified by the things I've
done and if you've come to tell me that
Michael wouldn't want me to hurt Henry
that he would want me to forgive I know
that too just in case you saw Kathleen
order the murder of a room full of
prisoners and thought maybe there's
still some good in her here's her I know
I'm wrong and evil and I don't care
speech No One's Gonna be here because my
plan worked premature celebration
[Music]
remember sniper this comically bad was
he a stormtrooper in another life
leaving your back door unlocked while
you're sniping that's how spies break in
and backstab you and even if you've got
a Razorback equipped they can still just
headshot you while your eyes in the
scope thinking you can spin fast enough
to shoot a man who's not only several
decades younger than you but is
absolutely draped in plot armor
Anthony had known about Joel's crew for
maybe two minutes at most and to get
from downtown Kansas City to that point
would take long enough that they could
Escape across the river unless of course
they move at season seven Gendry speed
really is a testament to the rig on
Stark School of running away from things
that their campus not only survived the
apocalypse but continued to graduate
students all the same well done you guys
well this is what happens when you [__]
with fate I'm not sure that this
happened to any character with Dr Fate
and I watched Justice League Unlimited
Young Justice and Black Adam
thank you
so you've killed and maimed and
monologued your way through Kansas City
the man who betrayed your brothers right
in front of you and your gun is drawn oh
look vengeance is at hand but wait that
flaming truck just sank under the ground
that's weird huh I could shoot Henry and
then turn but nah this deserves all of
my attention also a sinkhole that's a
shame Really Gonna lower the value of
that property it'll just be that much
harder for a hedge fund to turn the
house into six apartments and charge
triple the market rate for rent they'll
only be able to charge double now
leaving your chores undone that people
always come back to bite you eventually
zombie show remembers how to zombie
retreating as soon as fungus face showed
up you're like three feet away from
vehicles and 20 feet away from several
houses you could fortify
didn't he just reload it's nice of him
to still run out of ammo for dramatic
effect though
oh no Henry's gone from hiding behind
automobiles to hiding under them I love
Henry and Sam but their survival
instincts are complete and they're just
absolute trash at hide and seek
how the hell did Kathleen make it across
the entire chaos filled Battlefield
unscathed just think of all the cars she
must have had to hide behind for someone
so hellbent and focused on Revenge that
she literally sacrificed her entire city
she is very easily distracted from said
Revenge oh no someone's being murdered
by an infected let's stop and stare
because the same thing hasn't been
happening for the last 20 minutes you
know what herding infected was probably
easier than getting these three to move
consistently in a straight line look I
don't know exactly how I'm getting to
Wyoming I'm probably walking but if you
want to yeah yeah I think it'd be nice
for example of a friend let's touch and
go there for a while and they never
passed up an opportunity to stupidly
hide behind a car but I'm relieved Henry
and Sam made it I look forward to this
becoming their trademark skill in season
two
thinking either of these kids is going
to sleep after the horrors they've
witnessed this evening
well that's a weird question for him to
ask oh no I know you did not introduce
this adorable and lovable character just
to kill him off in a single episode
because that would be cruel and would
prevent me from getting attached to any
other characters for the length of the
series that's right your attempt to make
me care has made me care less you played
yourself show conso Joel and Henry
foregoing a bike check after that huge
battle seems like a big oversight that
neither of them would have made
his medicine okay that's a relief
Ellie's immune it's the whole point of
the show so now I'm sure she'll be able
to save Sam this couldn't be another and
even more manipulative and cruel trick
by the show Runners right hey no one is
more eager to save Sam than me but why
is she cutting the palm of all the
places to cut you choose somewhere
highly sensitive often dirty and it will
take forever to heal maybe it looks
dramatic on camera but for once it'd be
nice to see what common sense looks like
all right problem solved you had me go
in there for a second The Last of Us now
time for bed and more death defying
harrowing adventures in the morning wait
why does Cindy keep adding sins instead
of taking them away
uncapable promises look at these two
best friends for life cannot wait to see
the spin-off
you are really confusing me what the
hell man hey
why didn't he say hey back he's
obviously awake that's just rude oh and
apparently that's the end of the episode
wait why is this still going Cindy just
keeps muttering something about me being
a Wim concerned for my well-being
something about Phoebe from Friends
being old and yelling I can't figure it
out anyway not sure why I'm still here
or why the credits seem to have jumped
in so suddenly oh well Last of Us
remains my favorite show and I love how
it makes me feel Long Live jewelry sign
Henry
forcing the audience to relive this
trauma again you want to bring back my
favorite post-apocalypse gay couple as
well please don't when I cried after
episode three my wife said I sounded
like a raccoon with four broken legs we
made him soup if Pedro Pascal shows up
at my house with or without a gun I'm
making him soup hell I'll make him a
souffle I like candles I'll put on some
music and then oh I'm sorry it's
actually not in the TV since script
that's my fan fiction sorry about that
you look at anything like you bit and I
ain't seen him come on Joel you kind of
walked into that one you might be armed
with a gun but Graham Green's armed with
wit and you will lose to it every time
have you seen The Green Mile he's
fantastic you've got a map why are you
lost I must have missed all the street
signs in the enormous [__] Forest
foreign
Bella Ramsay but it'll never be enough
go ahead and remove another question I
didn't mean to upset you about your
brother apologizing to the man who just
a second ago had a gun pointed at you if
your brother's wish to the river he's
gone Michelle will disprove this theory
in about 20 minutes I'm okay I'm okay
are you you know what the best thing to
do during a panic attack is ask the
person suffering a bunch of Rapid Fire
questions that always calms me down when
I'm having a hole punch through my chest
by anxiety thinking you can survive a
Wyoming winter with just jeans I'm not
sure the writers have ever visited Green
River during the cold season but you
ain't walking around with just denim for
long each episode I'm hoping we've seen
the last of Joel and Ellie continuously
walking but each episode proves that
this will not be the last of me being
disappointed come down from there you're
gonna break your neck dads can I have
some though what just to warm up alcohol
warming up the body's a myth and can
actually lead quickly to hypothermia
especially under conditions such as the
ones Joel and Ellie are in Joel is a
terrible Father Figure and somehow
immune to hypothermia not sure which I
find more Cinema I mean probably the
father thing but he should still be
suffering from hypothermia also how does
Joel even still have alcohol when they
were forced to only take a few things
that he really believe alcohol was on
that level of importance cheap I would
raise sheep they're quiet Joel has
obviously never been to a farm before
sheep are most certainly not quiet they
will bleed every night you want quiet
grow some crops plants are quiet Sally
[__] lied actually her middle name is
Kristen you might want to reread some of
those books in the library Ellie Marlene
she's a lot of things but she's no fool
and she says they can do it they can do
it maybe but why is Joel believing this
all of a sudden he didn't want to keep
transporting Ellie until Tess made it or
dying wish for him to do just that he
flat out said he didn't believe there
was a possibility of a cure I know he
likes Ellie more but that changed his
entire opinion about the possibility of
a cure dream of sheep ranches on the
moon sheep ranches on the moon that's
almost as ridiculous as Whalers on the
moon who carry a harpoon and that is
quiet I checked my six I live for tracks
I found the high ground and I kept watch
you found The High Ground so you weren't
just taking lessons from din but from
Obi-Wan as well most impressive with me
before you go go random people on the
side of the bridge are random and they
appear to have cameras why do you call
it dressing it's like undressing because
it is it's like
undressing from the inside episode has
time for Ellie preparing her type five
damn you're nowhere Livingston so weird
that you name dropped the Revolutionary
War era New Jersey governor I don't see
what he has to do with this situation
see I didn't need to play the games to
get the show just needed my good
old-fashioned history degree that came
for the small price of forty thousand
dollars in student loans don't ask me I
don't have a clue no you could have just
made something up great suggestion I'm
sure he'll keep that in mind for later
and it will cause no trouble whatsoever
look at that River
crazy blue actually I believe that
particular shade in the river is
Cerulean blue not crazy blue
matures how about we just talk this
through how about you shut the [__] up
Wyoming units
[Music]
and he will rip you up then when the dog
just get infected I don't infectious
disease much but I've played Resident
Evil enough to know I don't want any
zombie dogs roaming the country now her
the dog wasn't growling at Joel upon
approach but is growling at Ellie even
though it smells nothing on her either
because I guess the dog has a great
sense of dramatic timing you'd think the
ranger Joe here after 20 years of living
in a world of fungus infected creatures
would understand that the mask going
over the nose is probably the most
important part of wearing the mask
unless of course it's a political
statement in which I guess you can list
the cause of death later is Free Speech
just looking for my brother it's all
nothing more huh what's her name we're
gonna find out Tommy is at this
settlement and Maria is his partner
still why did Maria immediately think oh
he's looking for his brother I'm sure
this is Tommy's brother there aren't
other people at the settlement with
missing family members and honestly the
idea that Joel would have wandered into
the territory of the specific settlement
that was housing Tommy is wild enough in
its own right I'm handing out five sins
of this whole operation and if anyone
has an issue with that they can meet me
at High Noon by the sycamore trees I
mean I won't be there because I hate
violence but the sycamore trees are very
pretty this time of year how the [__]
did they have enough spare horses for
Joel and Ellie to each get their own did
the group have two extra they brought
along for the hell of it or did these
horses not bear their former Masters to
Good Fortune it's been a while since
we've had a proper meal hey don't you
dare insult Florence's soup like that
you had a proper meal like two days ago
you draw power from a dam got that
working a couple years ago after that
sewage Plumbing water heaters bites
this place actually [__] works this
place actually [__] works Collective
ownership
so uh communism
ah I didn't like that it is that
literally this is the commune we're
communist admitting to being communists
which honestly would be like only the
176th thing to be scared of in this
post-apocalyptic venue it's right below
attacked by clowns and a few notches
above attacked by dogs dressed as clowns
holy [__] what is up with this random
hand and why is no one saying anything
about it I guess I could send a
community wasting any resources on a bar
but what strikes me more odd is that
there's a working bar in this town and
no one except Joel and Tommy are
currently at it unless we get bacon I
mean what's even left making getting
bacon your last priority go grab some
supplies and be out of your hair in the
morning telling someone you're stealing
some of their [__] without asking first
character who lost their child thinks
they see their child in a crowd and it
turns out to be someone else cliche I
have no idea who these people on the 10
hottest boys list are so this sentence
for Hocus Pocus you want to celebrate a
cool movie about witches from the 90s
get a [__] sticker for The Craft
comic golden tampons and pads after the
apocalypse so you you think the qz is
using resources to manufacture feminine
hygiene products and wage or not but
they're still making Viagra though
leaving a fire going in your house
unattended and yes I know lots of people
do this but it doesn't make it any less
dangerous or sinful I'm gonna get my
scissors
that's all just the ends I promise well
I'm sure these are all very kind
gestures forcing someone to accept your
generosity without consent is
problematic the new clothes are nice but
you didn't ask if she had sentimental
attachments to her previous outfit and
now you're pressuring her into a haircut
that she probably needs but might not be
comfortable with yet the only people who
can betray us are the ones we trust well
that's not even remotely true you don't
need to trust someone to get betrayed
you think Lando trusted Vader when they
struck their bargain in Cloud City not
even a little and yet he was betrayed
all the same forcing kids to watch the
goodbye girl or laying the metaphors on
too thick in your episode make your
choice I choose both I figured I'd save
you the trouble how does this town have
so many clothes and shoes that fit Joel
and Ellie so perfectly it's like that
scene from the second season of Prison
Break where Michael digs up all the
outfits laid out for him and the other
guys no one had a clue would be escaping
with him also any season after the first
season of prison break today I thought
that dog was gonna tear her apart
because it smelled something on her no I
didn't stand there what exactly was
y'all supposed to do if you tried to
save Ellie from The Dog most likely both
of them would have been shot and killed
that was a no-win situation and Joel
might have plenty to beat himself up
over but this is not one of those things
what exactly did you hear I have to
leave her you have to take her
eavesdropping poor kids make your choice
I choose both Maria told me about Sarah
no don't say another word great idea
Joel I think we should all just take a
second to think about the things we've
said and Skip I'm not sure as hell ain't
you dead hey Siri
set a reminder for the end of episode 8
to send it just in case Joel calls Ellie
like his baby girl or something I've set
that reminder would you like to hear
your list list of appointments for
tomorrow uh sure you have an appointment
with your therapist labeled recovering
from The Last of Us at 11 A.M yeah that
sounds about right can you say goodbye
or something no I came here to steal one
of these horses and go Force dramatic
timing is forced and honestly not all
that dramatic you deserve a choice I
still think you'd be better off with
Tommy let's go I'm glad to see them
reunited but doing it this fast kind of
sucks the energy out of their last
argument we should have waited an
episode that way we had a week to really
marinate in their upcoming separation
doing it here makes the fight in
subsequent reunion kind of feel cheap
riding a horse riding a horse riding a
horse River it's a contractor that's
pretty cool Chris Pine and most people
that watched it might disagree with you
Ellie if the fireflies were nice enough
to spray paint their image so you knew
where to find them they could have at
least spray painted an X over the image
when they hightailed it out of Dodge
there are definitely doctors here
pointing out the obvious of course I
like to call it pulling a Diana Troy
receiving Clickers
yeah no fireflies either maybe in all
that research they turned into
so teases us with humans turning into
monkeys but never shows us humans
turning into monkeys damn it all to Hell
hold up the fireflies have a base in
[__] Fort Smith Arkansas I am Memphis
and Oklahoma City but Fort Smith have
you been there I refuse to believe the
fireflies would invest resources for
operations there now theophil on the
other hand
every watch this fight five times and
nowhere in it did I see the Bandit get
enough momentum to stab Joel with his
Bat hell half the fight Joel was behind
the Raider so I'm calling [__] on
this reveal if you want to stab Joel
show the stabbing don't open your eyes
oh
episode will let us know Joel's fate
before fading to Black on yet another
cliffhanger
oh one full minute
fungus grow which literally happens
slower than paint drying for what it's
worth
come on asking the guy with a hole in
his abdomen for help running with a
Walkman on if they'd wanted you to do
that they'd have called it a run Minelli
also [__] PE actually PE might have
been interesting so pee you don't fight
[Laughter]
you think was gonna happen Bella Ramsay
is just over five feet tall and you
don't mess with short girls he'll kick
your [__] ass took a zombified giant
to kill her in the last HBO series did
you honestly think you were going to
give her walk away unscathed to pass
ahead of you
first path wait is this mug supposed to
represent the first path why do you
think you need visual examples to keep
two things in our minds or is it just
that the emptiness of the mug is
supposed to represent the emptiness of
this speech I can hold two ideas in my
mind without attaching them to random
physical objects Captain condescension
there's a leader in you wait I was
always told there were two wolves inside
of me now it's a leader is the leader
one of the Wolves or is the leader in
there a separate entity this metaphors
are hard at least you could have done
was explain it with a mug or something
is that it
that's it I'm with Ellie here she gives
Bethany 15 stitches and your complete
responses so you're willing to obey
rules from here on out so someday you
can lower your power over the girl you
just gave 15 stitches to yeah cool carry
on then
not giving Savage Starlight your full
interest and attention you could have
been the foggy of the Savage Starlight
Cinematic Universe Ellie and you threw
it all away from the moment Riley steps
into the room she acts like she's there
to murder Ellie going so far as to wake
her up by covering her mouth in a [__]
she'll try to say she meant it to be a
joke but I looked up the definition of
joke and it didn't say anything about a
TV show needing a cheap scare so it
makes a character act completely
opposite of their own self-interest also
Ellie has plenty of time before she
knows it's Riley to call out for help
but doesn't because she is also
apparently more interested in the work
the show needs to do
also also not keeping your window locked
during the Apocalypse in my mind you
loved it well then you obviously don't
know your best friend very well you know
what kind of jokes she likes puns next
time wake her up softly and tell her one
of those at least then you won't get
stabbed actually scratch that the last
pun I told got me stabbed three times
maybe just skip jokes to be safe sort of
crazy and you're gonna say no but then
you have to say yes looks like Riley
went to the Weinstein School of
understanding consent
the fear is gone
[Music]
my connections tired of taking chances
you trust me right I don't know
mysterious friend who disappears for
weeks at a time and breaks into my room
to startle me in my sleep do I trust you
I don't know should I trust you putting
your trust in someone to answer the
question as to whether or not you should
trust them it's like the TV show cliche
version of that thing where the one
guard always tells the truth and the
other one lies and then you have to ask
the right question of one of them to
know if the other one's the one that's
the liar or the truth guy I also think
there's like a melting ice block and a
horse named Sunday but I could be wrong
are they teaching you this at Firefly
University show taunts me with a firefly
spin-off where Kaylee and inara do
adjunct teaching to a bunch of Gorham
college students that will never
exists are better
congrats one point for the anarchists we
prefer Freedom Fighters somehow this
episode manages to do a ton of heavy
lifting on both the emotional backstory
of Ellie by crafting a relationship we
care about and making a point about
polarization in perspective and they
didn't even charge us an extra 15 bucks
just to watch the episode
scares well technically the opposite of
jumping so drop scares is that the first
dead body you ever saw asking this
question to anyone decades into a
fast-moving fungus monster outbreak
chicks like courage no like 40. or 50.
whatever anyways old whippersnappers I
mean kids movies and shows always make
it seem like the roofs are the most
stealthy and easiest way to Traverse big
cities but roofs are all different and
often spread out they're deadly death
traps of death unless you're an obese
elderly man with a strange penchant for
reindeer you should probably avoid them
at all costs it's a it's okay you don't
know everything
I agree I disagree no agree to disagree
is not a weapon to yield as a way to end
an argument that hasn't even begun agree
to disagree is an offering you make
after listening to each other first and
trying to come to an understanding once
it becomes clear no progress is being
made it's a way to part ways as fellow
humans instead of continuing to try to
change each other's minds stop using
agree to disagree as a way to tell me to
shut up I mean someone telling someone
to shut up them all you out of your
[__] mind the exact thing I said to
my friends every single Friday night of
my high school life somehow makes it
into the episode the amount of
electricity needed to light up and run
this entire mall would absolutely raise
some red flags somewhere in fedra I
think we're supposed to admire Ellie and
Riley Street smarts but doing stuff like
this is more like some Street dumbs no
one can see [__] but us that long arch
of skylights begs to differ unless of
course this particular Mall chose tinted
glass for all its Windows did it
probably not tonight I'm gonna show you
the four wonders of them all old people
walking Punk kids overpriced merchandise
and an immediate headache well at least
you got one of those covered no way and
by no way do you mean no way someone
would be this Amazed by an escalator
even in an apocalypse agreed you are
just a graceful ballerina don't you mean
ballerina
see that's the exact kind of joke that
got me stabbed last time nobody gets
gutted by the end of this dumb Teen
Movie you joke but think about this for
a second what is the scenario in which
someone leaves this place and doesn't
come back but also thinks they'll be
back in five freaking minutes I'm not
saying you couldn't concoct one but I am
saying this note is more likely to read
he who is Valiant and pure of spirit can
find me in the castle of
ah Gap Kids having a bigger reaction to
an escalator than a merry-go-round
drunk driving and you might be thinking
hold on they're riding horses not a car
but you can still be arrested for
driving a horse drunk don't ask me how I
know stand and guard while people shovel
could be worse you could be the one
shoveling why didn't you tell me any of
this I don't know that's a strange way
to pronounce because these scriptwriters
thought it worked better to say it here
so the audience could really feel the
depth of the pain of it in the moment
[__] you well look at that I came
prepared charging five dollars for a
photo booth that's just outrageous
should be three tops have you done this
before no idiot I was waiting to do it
with you considering all the ways this
thing could fail not testing it out
first might make you the idiot in this
situation Riley photo developing fluid
lasts 18 months in the best of
conditions that one's not bad sure but
you also did the scary pose last so why
is it third on the printouts yeah I'm
the same [__] that spent an hour
yesterday breaking this because somehow
nobody else thought to do this when she
started going down and the population
was looting everything they could smash
the buttons competitive Smash Brothers
players also playing Mortal Kombat 2
this much when Galaga is right [__]
there
choosing Raiden a second time instead of
picking someone cool like Jax Melina's
gonna kick your ass again
I mean I'll be your best friend again
it's a dinosaur basing your friendships
on a person's ability and willingness to
pull a Jurassic Park for you what did
the frustrated cannibal do eat
themselves out I may have the wrong pun
book
this whole fight could have been avoided
if Riley hadn't given Ellie her birthday
gift where the [__] bombs are why do
it here do that [__] on a table in the
food court or any other of the hundreds
of rooms inside the mall I didn't find a
small did you they posted you here ah
the show the constant gut punches well
at least I know this is the last one for
this episode tonight's my last name
decided to go full rileo and Elliot and
somehow I'm buying it stupid emotions
where's the freaking hot chocolate lady
when I need her
she screams will end up being a
Halloween decoration because the episode
hadn't met its fake out tension quota
yet
it was like to have a family
to belong
I mean
thank you
in this music sucks saying the music
sucks and then proceeding to play I Got
You Babe by Sonny and Cher as if it's
not an absolute Bop this new nightmare I
get to have for the rest of my life put
your ass up here encouraging your friend
to stand on glass that may or may not
hold your combined weight
between this episode and episode 3 The
Last of Us continues to explore the
queerness of its characters in a
meaningful way that both validates
on-screen representation and doesn't
make a big deal out of same-sex
relationships once an offer handling
Ali's queerness with such respect
instead of ignoring it or using it for a
cheap gag
getting knocked the [__] out by simply
falling down
oh it's your celebration
or you could be forcing your best friend
to confront you as an infected and kill
you you don't know that you'll turn at
the same time just gonna add a
retroactive sand for the previous
episode where Joel told Ellie she didn't
know what losses and you might say hey
you can't add a sin retroactively and
I'll remind you that we make the rules
around here
putting an old needle that's been on the
floor in Joel's body without sterilizing
it he's got a flask with booze dip that
[__] inside first also not giving Joel
anything to bite down on but his coat
sleeve in his mouth or something this
isn't Pleasant also also not offering
Joel a drink from his flask before doing
surgery that makes first aid from a
Civil War battlefield looked merciful by
comparison also times three and most
importantly using a running Stitch
instead of an interrupted Stitch
Revelation 21 The Book of Revelation
also Revelation also also I know we
haven't seen the man speaking yet but
I'm already sniffing an overdone evil
preacher in an apocalypse hiding behind
religion to do evil cliche exacerbated
by the fact that out of all the
scripture to put into a sermon he went
with the big book of apocalyptic imagery
written by a man in Exile the Tabernacle
of God hi there viewers a quick note
from one of the TV sins writers here
what is this I wanted to make a joke
about God's Tabernacle sounding rude but
Aaron the narrow hey that's me said it
was just my mind being in the gut
because it was and I should leave it
alone so as Revenge I'm gonna make him
say Tabernacle 10 times Tabernacle
Tabernacle Tabernacle Tabernacle
Tabernacle Tavern look I'm not Ron
Burgundy here I have free will and the
point was even if it does sound rude
you're not sinning the show you're fired
also I have no writers I make up all of
this on my own and God shall wipe away
all tears from their eyes
kids roll flag Marshalls the ground is
too cold to dig we'll bury your father
in the spring is it cremation a better
option all around they get to have their
memorial and you get to hide the
evidence of all the secret cannibaling
by just giving the family an urn of
Ashes everyone wins wait how much do we
have left look at the hotel in rations
maybe a week having a conversation about
dwindling Food Supplies out in the open
and risking your subservient flaw
quickly transforming into a riotous mob
ah stop showing me this disgusting
bloody wound I have enough context clues
from the director and editor in this
scene without the makeup Department
feeling the need to flex as well Ellie
you asks why are you torturing this poor
man with dry jerky goodness that he
can't possibly reach what's he gonna do
tongue it into his mouth hope that the
rat from end game nudges it in there
pray that it decomposes and gets
absorbed into his skin
don't tell Joel you're going to be right
back if you plan on hunting you're gonna
give the guy an anxiety attack as a
quick potty break turns into I'll see
you in a few hours because I'm gonna
hike through the woods and kill a deer
well what do you think what else anyway
you know I'm just gonna assume that
gunshot we heard was Bigfoot cracking a
knuckle medicine like for infections I
understand Ellie needs to specify
antibiotics but in a world where
infected is associated with the Fung
apocalypse I'd be more direct about the
origin of the infection and I'll leave
quite so much room for the
interpretation it's hard to trust
strangers I know but I honestly mean you
no harm but if a stranger says they
honestly mean you no harm then you can
totally trust them and I honestly won't
send this for being something only
sketchy villains say and for what it's
worth there's room for you in our group
if you want you inviting me to your
hunger Club thanks Ali would be served
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
at TV sins
some weird cult thing well you sort of
kind of got me there I am a preacher but
just pretty standard bible stuff yeah
but if that pretty standard bible stuff
is including the Old Testament we're
talking about slavery stoning women for
premarital sex and plenty other
cornerstones that make most cults look
like enthusiastic bloggers this isn't as
reassuring as you think it is David no
such thing as luck no I I believe
everything happens for a reason I'd love
for this to become a four-hour
philosophical Treatise exploring the
concepts of Divine Providence Free Will
determinism and random chance but I
honestly don't think any of you would
want that even if you think you might
I'll just say this if your go-to tenant
is everything happens for a reason you
better be prepared to give account for
some pretty nasty [__] you just hand
waved away it does I can prove it to you
the story David shares is about being
led to Ellie and Joel after they killed
one of his people in his
indistinguishable from luck so no he
can't prove it James lower the gun and
of course James turns up at the perfect
time to hear this story and be outraged
in at a perfect time to catch Ellie off
guard she didn't kill anybody she has
and he couldn't have possibly known one
way or the other I know you're not with
a group you actually don't know David
for all you know Ellie and Joel were
scavengers for a large group you weren't
even there stop making characters
omniscient just so you can dismiss
possible plot holes I can protect you if
you're trying to get someone to trust
you maybe don't say things kylo Ren
would say oh wait a second you don't
know who that is because the apocalypse
killed the sequels hey maybe there's a
silver lining to this timeline after
Ally gets unbelievably lucky here I know
that injecting a penicillin shot into
the wound sounds logical but I still
feel like Ellie took the old stab in the
dark adage a bit too literally showing
us every disgustingly excruciating
purulent skin piercing second of this
yes let's leave the t-shirt covered in
infected blood over the infected wound
you just risked your life to disinfect
what is it venison just [__] say dear
you're not presenting it to Gordon
Ramsay
big one bringing a dead animal to a
place where people are actively eating
dinner take the damn thing to a side
door and stop swinging around while
everyone's eating
don't give the horse snow melted so the
horse has water eating snow without any
other form of water actually dehydrates
you and forces the body to use more
water to melt the snow and regulate your
internal temperature I know the horse is
going to die in a few minutes anyway but
come on Ellie this man's not already
dead he's dangerous which makes me
wonder why you waited so long to pursue
them both neither Joel is dead and Ellie
has no reason to hang around overnight
or you're giving Joel time to heal
instead of attacking when you know he's
weak also nothing says being careful
like staying grouped together and
walking down the middle of the street I
mean to question your sense of Mercy
David we bring that girl back with us
she's just another mouth revealing that
you're about to do a thing by starting
your sentence saying you don't intend to
do the thing if we leave her out here
she'll die yeah maybe that's God's will
I will silence you with my silence
because my silence is much more powerful
than your very valid point but really
the answer is that these guys could
easily hunt and kill Ellie but the show
needs to keep her alive so we get the
big baby girl moment at the end I'm not
saying it's not worth it I just want us
to be honest about it
if anybody makes it down here you got it
let's talk about Ellie's plan she's
leaving Joel pretty much defenseless
while she runs off to get captured the
men don't know what house they're in so
why not barricade yourselves in hide and
buy time for Joel to wake up even if
they do find you you're missing out on
the perfect opportunity to Home Alone
some Ellie's Galloping away at full
speed and this [__] just so happens
to be in the perfect position to take
the horse out do it
listen ammo has to be scarce for
everyone in the future but especially
over this isolated cannibal immunity so
as punctuating your intentions with a
rifle shot the best way to use said ammo
you so hungry for vengeance deliver it
judging their bloodlust when the only
reason you're pushing so hard to keep
Ellie alive is so you can make her into
a child bride and or a paratif
Joel not only survives Ellie's first aid
but is also strong enough to stand up
and kill this man after one night's rest
I started worrying you wouldn't wake up
why you're literally gonna eat her why
don't we just start with your name
each really has a lot to learn about
buying time to escape by being nicer to
your captors
Timothy
Joel finding the strength to take out
Timothy was so ridiculous the camera
refused to even film it in fact it's so
ridiculous that I can feel grogu
reaching from the Mandalorian into this
series to help Joel out it's okay
unbelievable wasting what little
strength you've regained on a blunt
force instrument for murder instead of
just using the knife again
he gets found out because the people
butchers left a [__] ear on the floor
next to the cage do you want ants
because this is how you get ants and
exposed as a cannibal you're an animal
well yes we all are that's sort of the
point yes [__] but you know that's
not what she meant she's fully aware
that not all animals are cannibals just
as we're well aware that you can have a
show set after the apocalypse it doesn't
contain Bible thumping dictators it just
seems to happen a lot but what was I
supposed to do let them starve no but I
feel like we might be skipping the many
many many many many steps between let
them starve and feed them to each other
didn't he take another man's life to
save yours
he was defending you well don't think
that helps your argument David Joel's
killing someone to protect a little girl
and what you're doing is killing someone
so you can eat them forgive me if I lean
towards favoring the guy that doesn't
hold Hannibal Lecter as a spiritual
leader you remind me of me you're a
natural leader you're smart loyal you're
getting all that from a fireside chat
and her refusal to share her name yes it
happens to be true but how does he know
that did he get screeners for the first
seven episodes what does cordyceps do is
it evil no it loves not quite sure I've
seen enough evidence thus far to believe
this fungus is capable of love and no I
refuse to include that frigally erotic
makeout session in episode 2. think of
what we could do together as strong as
we are no offense David but Vader's join
me was a little more persuasive
look at me
Troy Baker uh thanks for calling me back
listen sorry you lost out on the role of
Joel to Pedro Pascal but but listen we
we still want you in the show and I've
got a really great part for you okay so
check this out you're a cannibal that
gets killed by Ellie with a Cleaver
because your friend was dumb enough to
leave a knife right next to her
unrestrained hand pretty cool right
Troy Ellie why are you wasting time with
the log you've got a room full of
Windows and chairs smash window exit
Escape let's fed her teaching these kids
[Music]
wow Ellie threw that log in the one spot
it would catch something on fire talk
about lucky I I mean uh talk about
everything happening for a reason David
seems totally chill with the fact that
this Lodge made of wood is on fire as if
he knows grogu is on his way from
knocking out Timothy to prevent this
fire from spreading I know you're not
infected no one infected fights this
hard to stay alive man this is just an
episode of David making very confident
assessments based on [__] all knowledge
he's one Proclamation short of becoming
the dunning-kruger of post-apocalyptic
cult leaders you don't know what I could
have given you oh I think she knows
exactly what you could have given her
David you made that abundantly and
creepily clear Exodus 22 6 was that
ceiling beam soaked in kerosene
listen it is hard for me to hoop and
cheer at the sight of a 14 year old
brutally bludgeoning a man's face with a
meat cleaver even if said man is a child
seducing cannibal having said that Bella
Ramsay sells this so well I have to
acknowledge the voice inside me that is
currently screaming yeah [__] that
[__] up Ellie turn his face into
pulpy potato dolphin wall
so when David said there's no way out
Ellie the doors are locked even all the
doors are locked other than this fire
escape that Ellie will conveniently find
now that's Danger's passed it's lies
like this that give the church a bad rep
David yes yes cannibalism too but no one
likes a liar
no
damn it Joel you just recovered from one
near-death injury so why are you so
eager for Ellie to give you another was
the penicillin high that good it's okay
baby girl
they did it they did the thing oh they
did the thing but also do you make me
want to save the heartfelt reunion for
when you aren't still dangerously close
to the people whose population you've
decreased by half a dozen whose leader
you've killed in whose home is burning
down thanks to you also also are there
no guards in this town that would come
investigate gunshot screaming the
building on fire or is the show implying
that grogu killed all of them too I love
how the series brought in the voice
actor for Ellie do you think she got
paid much or was this opening scene a
labor of love look if the delivery of
that pun had you groaning buckle up
because they don't get any better after
birth
here's a sin for anyone ingest or
otherwise who's ever made the yeah but
you've never experienced being kicked in
the ball's argument
wow that was like the ideal birth I mean
minus the zombie attack getting bitten
the high risk of infection the ass
splinters and the thought of raising a
child in The Apocalypse of course but
man at least it was quick hey I remember
you you're the uh yeah the lady from the
place I know she's important because his
flashlights lingered on her for so long
who is she again damn it show would have
previously on if killed you
take her with you to Boston
find someone to bring her up
volunteering your child to be raised in
Boston
wrapping a baby up with a flick knife
you know sometimes life hits you with
senses you just never thought you'd have
to say
how long have we known each other
as if it has any bearing on the fact
that this baby could be seconds away
from turning into a mushroom zombie as
if babies weren't annoying enough
already
crap right now and then you kill me I
don't know Anna this feels pretty
[__] selfish you've got a knife can't
you do it yourself you're asking your
best friend to live with the memory of
killing her best friend for the rest of
her life also knowing how important
Ellie is to Marlene it is insane that
she trusts her with Joel and Tess I mean
it is a stroke of ridiculous good luck
that Joel ends up being as solid as he
does cover her ears cover her ears cover
her ears you're in close space about to
fire a gun when you go to a shooting
range you wear earplugs and extra sound
protection over them you've got a
newborn baby there with developing ears
take her outside or even downstairs
covering her ears won't do also he does
not
casting Ashley Johnson in this critical
role but only letting us have her for 9
minutes and 50 seconds Beefaroni Chef
Boyardee have you ever played this as if
the apocalypse wasn't Bleak enough Here
Comes Jolie to add tinned beef and
Boggle talk about bad luck military
drops bombs not one of them hits the
building you're trying to demolish yes
I'm sure that was the bad luck the
contractors were focusing on and not the
fact that the world was ending around
them along with their livelihoods
[Music]
kids also why are we worried about loud
noises anymore did that just stop being
a thing how does Joel know that this
place is free of cordyceps
you better come take a look at this
cliche it's a magical moment in the game
and I'm happy to see this nod but how
the [__] have giraffes of All Creatures
survive 20 years into the apocalypse
also how exactly did she spot them from
the top of the ladder when Joel gets to
the top he doesn't see anything and then
chases her ass at multiple flights of
steps before seeing what she sees Ellie
being able to spot the giraffes is about
as realistic as well the drafts being
there in the first place Joel and Ellie
look upon the family of giraffes as a
Wonder of Nature and a brief respite
from the world of violence and suffering
instead of the three meals a day and
fashionably warm clothing that they
truly are is it everything you hoped for
got it suction down you can't deny that
for you hey I remember that that was the
uh the uh the thing they said at the
place I know it's important because of
the deliberate delivery damn it Joe
would have previously on have killed you
I've always been through everything I've
done it can't be for nothing it can
promise
cheap ranch
the moon will follow you anywhere you go
unless there's a particularly cool zoo
animal on the loose in which case I'm
ditching you quicker than you can say
Left Behind bye we finished what we
started which HBO means two seasons of
material stretched into five followed by
five and ounce spin-offs nobody asked
for only one of which will actually make
it to air before being canceled so what
was wrong with you it's for this uh the
guy who shot and missed hey I remember
that that was the uh the uh the thing
they said at the place the image show
would have previously honored what did a
green grape say to the purple grape
grieve you idiot oh I've got one what do
you call an early morning surprise
attack an AM Bush
if you hadn't been so busy punting maybe
you'd have seen that one coming I had
five minutes only job was to protect me
I still almost got killed
how'd you do it a Nifty Little Thing
Called plot armor you see Joel has to
stay alive so they can be the hero of
the story and choose to sacrifice the
person he holds most deer for the
greater good right you would be one
person I never wanted to be in debt to
but I owe you I mean to be fair you only
have to give him a battery and some
supplies that was the original deal
right he chose to take Ellie further
than the original agreement our doctor
he thinks that the cordycepsinelli has
grown with her since birth he thinks it
could be a carriage hole he thinks it
could she's happy to sacrifice Ellie's
life on the unproven hypothesis of one
doctor I'm sure everyone's desperate for
a cure at this point but we're talking
about removing a child's brain based on
a maybe it produces a kind of chemical
messenger it makes normal cordyceps sync
the cheese cordyceps it's why she's
immune then why does she still get
attacked by them shouldn't they think
that she's one of them and ignore her if
not why aren't they attacking each other
and furthermore why do I keep trying to
find logic in a made-up cure for a
made-up infection also how long has Joel
been unconscious if the answer isn't
several [__] weeks I want to know how
this doctors figured everything out so
quickly and with the level of confidence
that makes Ellie aside acceptable please
you don't understand I'm the only one
who understands attempting to have a
monopoly on guilt slash obligation slash
parenting slash the greater good or
whatever the [__] it is these two are
using to justify their own brand of
murder walking onto the highway leaving
there with this pack considering we're
talking about a woman who is
lobotomizing the child of her best
friend this seems like an oddly
sentimental Choice letting Joel go might
be the right thing to do but why the
[__] does she care about that she knows
his reputation kill him Joel will
contemplate his Escape for all of the
very long walk through the hospital
sometime while also somehow not being
nearly long enough to justify the
magnitude of what he's about to do he
said keep walking
thanks to the magic of Quick Cuts and
super fast editing this works
you don't have the bullets for this
either you've already shot the guy in
the leg and alerted the whole Hospital
what more was he going to do bleed on
you man this show really did capture a
lot of cool details from the game but
even included the mod that makes Joel
invulnerable to gunfire
[Music]
straight murder Joel tears through this
Hospital in a way that makes John Wick
look like Mr Rogers I feel like we're
supposed to admire Joel's determination
to save Ellie at whatever costs but it's
a rough watch when the people he's
determinating are just doing their jobs
and likely have no [__] clue what's
happening to Ellie or why she's ready
Joe awakes from his concussion argues
with Marlene then the raid redemptions
his way through the hospital and manages
to arrive seconds before Ellie's surgery
is about to begin seconds this is insane
timing people doctors who and brown
could have teamed up and still not
pulled this off so perfectly how did you
get in here he said as if the answer
[__] matters I won't let you take her
bringing a scalpel to a gunfight also
I'm sure killing that surgeon won't have
any consequences down the line or in
season two yep no further problems will
result from killing that doctor not even
one Laura Bailey plays a character that
should be healing but instead focuses on
doing damage cliche also teasing us with
Laura Bailey but without even a gesture
of 25 words of dialogue trusting any
elevator during the Apocalypse lips I
wouldn't enter an elevator until Society
had been rebuilt and even then I'd still
wait a decade or two and only if my
knees are really acting up so what would
she decide maybe you know the answer to
this if you'd bothered to ask before
lying and sedating her sure Joel's
violating Ellie's autonomy by making the
decision for her but you don't get to
claim any moral High Ground when you
didn't ask her either Marlene even after
what you've done we can still find a way
the bullet lodged in the brain of that
surgeon would likely take issue with
this claim Raiders attacked the hospital
I barely got you out of there lying and
not just lying but lying badly by adding
unnecessary layers to the LIE which
makes you look about as suspicious as a
50-something year old man driving away
from a hospital with a sedated teenager
in a flop sweat
you just come after her Joel chooses
cold-blooded murder again and I just
missed the days of Pedro Pascal playing
a Charming Prince Space Cowboy or drug
dealer
driving driving
wasting valuable minutes of your finale
mint also the border between Wyoming and
Utah doesn't look like this it's mostly
flat but you would know that when you
film everything in [__] Canada well
Sarah and I used to hike like this all
the time in Texas not a lot of mountains
to hike in Texas unless you made a lot
of trips from Austin over to Guadalupe
Mountains National Park even that's an
eight-hour drive are you gonna drive
eight hours to hike all the time I don't
think so anyway the point is driving in
Texas sucks more trolls sucks more
hiking sucks or whatever point I was
making I swear to me that everything you
said about the fireflies is true
I swear sure a man on a scale of one two
really [__] guilty that loaded pause
ranks a solid puppy sitting next to a
pile of poop pointing at the goldfish
okay Ellie believes this or has been
Stockholm syndromed into believing it
either way I'm fascinated to see how
this turns out and I'm sure it won't be
neutered by something like a five-year
time Jump
the game is absurd I want my money back
how do I get my quarters stuff all the
clocks cut off the telephone
prevent the dog from barking with a
juicy bone concrete guy is going to be
there yeah they said maybe you do it for
the air that will be displaced and most
of all you do it for the [__]
concrete
the voicemail box of Sterling Archer is
full
idiot God damn it
are you aiming for these people
okay you're okay you're gonna be okay
you have been found guilty by the Elders
of the town of uttering the name of our
Lord
and so as a blessed fever you are to be
stoned to death I want you to forget
this ever happened okay lines up
straight like that right to the right of
it and to the left of it are Pockets
right in those pockets of money look in
either one of them pay the bill
I'm not even supposed to be here today
on a daily basis I consume enough drugs
to sedate Manhattan Long Island and
queens for a month so let's go hunt that
and get our battery
and then we'll go find Tommy
Tommy this is the way Brightest Day
in Blackest Night
no evil fellas gave my side if you want
me to look for the light and I'll break
your jaw I won't tell anyone about any
of this I swear where are you gonna go
where are you gonna go where are you
gonna run Where Are You Gonna hide
yes
is that chicken silent breed is people
bam I'm eight years old you think I'd be
here alone I don't think so but when we
get to 20 tell me I'm gonna throw up
that was
that was Jesus Christ that's Jason
Bourne give me some sugar baby
this means something
now don't take this wrong way but you
are a Terminator right yes Sabaton
systems model 101 I think my legs might
be broken but I'll try to stand up
I haven't eaten in two days a census
taker once tried to test me I ate his
liver with some fava beans and a nice
Chianti what's your name I'm Ron Swanson
tears but a scratch
it's like looking in a mirror only not
okay but just know you can't escape for
Livingston
[Applause]
it's actually before my time
the winner though
why did the Scarecrow get an award
because he works with the Avengers
what if you don't find him oh well how
do you know I'm a hard worker I set high
goals and I've been told that I'm
persistent I don't know what to say
really three minutes to the biggest
battle of our professional lives all
comes down to today you put it in your
pack
you'll shoot your eye out kid
look at those kids but when we get to 20
tell me I'm gonna throw up did it make
you feel better did it make you feel
safe how does it make you feel now these
kids
like all of us are a part of a community
what is it with you kids every other day
it's food food
[Music]
my bad guy I'm bad that's good
this was actually it's the big wooden
box a big wooden box that nothing could
get inside of what's in the box
all right all right Mickey's a mouse
Donald the duck Pluto's a dog what's
goofy put your hands up no what why not
I don't want to
foreign
s don't shake hands Brothers gotta hold
on
let me help you out to pass ahead of you
Meryl Streep or Madonna huh
[__] off
close your eyes I want four clothes
trust me yes
[Music]
dude yeah dude
let's go lesbians let's go I sensed out
in there
[Music]
too much human meat and the very same
goes for Ezekiel which brings us back to
our starting point the nine tenets of
constancy perhaps you could toss me a
Band-Aid or some anti-bacterial cream I
fear it might be angriness you look like
a room a well scrubbed hustling a robe a
little taste
taste good nutrition has given you some
length of the bone but you're not more
than one generation from poor white
trash the atheists go to hell no
how about people who say they are not
religious but they are spiritual
Straight to Hell To The Boiler Room of
hell all the way down hands away the
Baddies
hey you you're finally awake
thank you
hey now what is that uh this would be a
giraffe Isaac Newton is it everything
you hoped for
Utah home of America's most powerful
weirdos moon rocks tastes better than
Earth rots why
because they're meteor that's not funny
that's not funny at all what surgery I'd
like to take his face off
are you doing keep walking this must
have register on an emotional level
first distract Target
then block his blind jab count with
cross to left cheek
discombobulate swear to me that
everything you said about the fireflies
is true I swear
I don't believe you